[Applause]
yeah so have you thought that we were
leaving all that Khloe Kardashian
Tristan Thompson drama in 2019 think
again on Monday Kim and her hubby Kanye
West were spotted sitting courtside at
the Cleveland Cavaliers LA Lakers game
in Los Angeles refresher
Tristan plays for the Cavaliers and it
seemed like Kim's beef with Tristan was
water under the bridge when she shared
this pick of the NBA star on her instace
Tori supportive right but then there was
this
[Applause]
that's Tristan prepping to shoot a free
throw and that's Kim seemingly booing
him savage a bunch of fans caught the
moment on their phones and to be fair
maybe she was just clapping or having a
little sportsman like no shade intended
heckling either way it's no secret that
Kim was super mad at Tristan after he
allegedly cheated on Chloe who was
pregnant at the time with her daughter
true like I don't even know how to
describe it besides it's just so
naturally Keeping Up with the
Kardashians cameras rolled on all that
drama what a loser
literally what a loser it just means
when I see him I'm going to like spit on
him Chloe took him back only to find out
he allegedly cheated on her again this
time with her sisters besties
Jordan woods
[Music]
yeah the cameras caught all that - it's
just you know things happen and of
course I'm sorry and apologetic as much
as I can be but one person who didn't
tune in to see all hell break loose
Chloe I personally don't watch it back
because I just I already know what
happens and it it's just I think a
little too toxic for me to keep reliving
stuff like that so I stay off social I
don't I didn't watch it and it's just a
part of our job that we kind of have to
do so we can't just pick and choose what
we want to show that's not fair and so
that's just what it is since then the
two have managed to keep things friendly
and are working on co-parenting their
adorable little girl I think working on
your personal growth internally is
something that will be a forever mission
and I always want to evolve and grow and
mature emotionally because that's how we
become better people while the world is
changing around us we should adapt to
that too but always remember to be kind
and just courteous of what's happening
around you too so I don't ever want that
to change
and when et caught up with Chloe and her
sisters in November she didn't exactly
shut down the idea of dating again you
guys have been through so much in your
life well what do you look what are you
looking for now you're not looking I'm
not but I'm not like in ten I'm just
super happy and content and I'm focused
on work and like taking care of me my
body and soul and true and I just I'm
having so much fun with her and what I
want to I will it's not some deliberate
thing yeah she ain't that hard about
Tristan also attended the famous
family's annual Christmas Eve party and
took this pic with Chloe and true so
that brings us up to speed and right
back to Kim and Kanye's basketball
outing
I think that we should note that Kim
showed up in some snakeskin pants and 20
toed heeled boots and rocked her shades
inside and so did Kanye but the couple
appeared to be living their best life
snacking on Stadium food and chatting it
up with Courtney Cox who was sitting
right next to them and if Kim was in
fact booing Tristan let this be a
warning do not mess with Kim's family of
course et will be here to help you keep
up with all of the Kardashians so make
sure to keep it locked right here until
next time I'm Hallie Stephens bye for
now
[Music]